Lucia: 还是二楼的客厅
Lucia: It's still the living room on the second floor.
Jake: 要装饰就一楼吧
Jake: If we want to decorate, let's do the first floor.
Jake: 然后还有各位的房间
Jake: And then there's everyone's rooms.
Jake: 我可能找个时间
Jake: I might find some time.
Jake: 今天或者明天或者等你们收拾好
Jake: Today, tomorrow, or whenever you guys finish tidying up.
Jake: 总之就是
Jake: Anyway,
Jake: 这几天我会把整个房子用iPhone扫一遍
Jake: In the next few days, I'll scan the whole house with an iPhone.
Jake: 嗯然后各位的卧室就收拾收拾
Jake: And you guys just tidy up your bedrooms.
Jake: 对要扫进去
Jake: Yes, it needs to be scanned.
Lucia: 那你要不扫之前通知一声
Lucia: How about you notify us before scanning?
Lucia: 对这样我就可以在扫之前
Lucia: So I can lift that box before you scan.
Lucia: 把那个箱子拉起来
Lucia: Lift that box up before you scan.
Alice: 微微
Tasha: Weiwei
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 你困啊
Tasha: Are you sleepy?
Alice: 我还不困
Katrina: I'm not sleepy yet.
Lucia: 要不然把它拔了
Lucia: How about just unplugging it?
Lucia: 哈哈呃你看一下它有多少电
Lucia: Haha, check how much battery it has.
Jake: 如果电很多的话没关系哦
Jake: If it has plenty of battery, it's fine.
Lucia: 我在手机上能看
Lucia: I can check on my phone.
Lucia: 到它有多少电对
Lucia: To see how much battery it has.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 原来它在这
Katrina: Yeah, I found it here again.
Lucia: 93%页是不是应该可以把
Lucia: 93%, that should be enough, right?
Jake: 可以OK
Jake: Yes, okay.
Jake: 对你坐着的时候冲嘛
Jake: Charge it while sitting,
Jake: 然后站着就还剩这些最后这
Jake: And then when standing, it has this last bit left.
Tasha: 最后一二三四五六六块没有
Tasha: The last one, two, three, four, five, six pieces are not found.
Tasha: 找着家了
Tasha: Found home.
Alice: 看看像不像嗯像
Tasha: Does it look like it? Yes, it does.
Tasha: 但不一定他们俩在一起感觉
Tasha: But not necessarily, they feel together.
Tasha: 这个在这边
Tasha: This one is here.
Lucia: 他怎么突然变成network Arrow了
Shure: How did it suddenly turn into network Arrow?
Jake: 好我看一下
Jake: Okay, let me see.
Jake: 可以给我看一下吗
Jake: Can you show me?
Jake: 就是在我把电拔掉之后
Jake: After I unplugged it.
Lucia: 他突然变成这个界面了
Lucia: It suddenly turned into this interface.
Lucia: 是哎对这样
Lucia: Yes, like this.
Shure:  你先把这几个字这个什么意思对齐
Shure: First, align these words, what does this mean?
Alice:恩，不行。
Jake: 重开一下
Jake: 我也没见过
Lucia: 就是这样关掉
Shure:  先先先来这个先先把一根给一边
Shure:  给那什么好
Jake: 我这出不来
Shure:  你把那缩一下
Tasha: 这样这个猪就塞不下他
Jake: 这个长度是对的吗
Jake: 都一样的
Shure:  都是一样
Katrina:  的
Lucia: 啊出来了他应该还是正常的吧
Lucia: 对可能是刚才有什么bug了嗯
Jake: 或者装饰二楼
Jake: 因为二楼的那个场地
Jake: 就做PPT比较方便
Jake: 就是就可以摆那个
Jake: 摆摆椅子
Jake: 摆很多椅子
Jake: Set up lots of chairs.
Lucia: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right, right.
Lucia: 因为二楼的桌子椅子
Alice:它像不像一家的
Jake: 对所以在二楼装饰
Alice: Yeah, so decorate the second floor.
Tasha: 他们这家该放哪里呢
Tasha: Where should they put these?
Shure:  是让毛血刷的
Shure: They’re for Mao Xue brushing.
Alice: 但我觉得他俩又不像一家
Shure: Haha, but I don’t think they look like a pair.
Alice: 因为这个角不太好拼
Alice: Because this corner is tricky to fit.
Alice: 就比较尖的角
Alice: It's a pretty sharp corner.
Alice: 有没有比较尖的角
Alice: Is there a sharper corner?
Alice: 他的嘴是吗
Tasha: His mouth, right?
Jake: 就剩了一圈了
Tasha: Haha, it's left a circle.
Jake: 这一圈很强
Jake: This circle is strong.
Lucia: 但是感觉只有
Lucia: But it feels like only...
Lucia: 只有这几个是比较确定的
Lucia: Only these few are more certain.
Lucia: 我们找到了很多两个
Lucia: We found many pairs.
Lucia: 两个是一起的
Lucia: Two of them go together.
Lucia: 但是确定了放在哪里
Lucia: But we figured out where to place them.
Alice: 但是找不到他们的家
Lucia: Of course, can't find their home.
Jake: 好多好朋友
Jake: So many good friends.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun
Lucia: 哇哎这个真的好一致啊
Lucia: Wow, this is really consistent.
Jake: 我去
Lucia: Oh my, this is...
Lucia: 这个你是怎么找到的
Katrina: How did you find this?
Tasha: 他这有两个尖尖
Tasha: It has two pointy ends here.
Tasha: 我去这尖尖你能看到
Tasha: Wow, you can see these pointy ends.
Jake: 眼神真好
Jake: You have good eyesight.
Jake: 我这看不清
Jake: I can't see clearly from here.
Tasha: 哦这个弧度我之前看到过
Tasha: Oh, I've seen this curve before.
Jake: 有点6
Jake: Pretty impressive.
Shure:  人生的最后7天
Shure: The last 7 days of life.
Shure:  来吧立起来
Shure: Come on, stand it up.
Lucia: 会不会是那个鸟翅膀
Lucia: Could it be that bird's wing?
Shure:  哦还有一个是吗
Shure: Oh, there's another one, right?
Shure:  对还有一个
Shure: Yes, there's another one.
Shure:  还有这个人
Shure: And this person.
Alice: 完美
Shure: Perfect.
Tasha: 哎棒棒棒棒
Katrina: Wow, amazing, amazing.
Alice: 那说明鸟不在边边
Tasha: That means the bird isn't on the edge.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 这个这个
Tasha: This, this.
Tasha: 感觉这个弧度很
Tasha: Feels like this curve is...
Tasha: 像
Tasha: Like...
Tasha: 不像哎
Tasha: Not really.
Jake: 确实有点像
Jake: It does look a bit like it.
Lucia: 哎对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 这个也是对的
Lucia: This one is also correct.
Jake: 这是你记住的吗嗯
Jake: Did you remember this?
Tasha: 然后
Tasha: Then...
Katrina:  再
Katrina: Again...
Tasha: 拿
Tasha: Take...
Alice: 像又不太像
Alice: One, right?
Lucia: 我们刚才是不是给这个蛇
Lucia: Did we just give this snake...
Lucia: 已经找到了一个小伙伴
Lucia: A little friend already?
Lucia: 对蛇跟那个熊猫哎
Lucia: Yeah, the snake and the panda.
Tasha: 怎么怎么怎么弄来着
Tasha: How did we do that again?
Lucia: 啊对对对
Lucia: Ah, right, right.
Alice: 有人长这样吗
Alice: Does anyone look like this?
Lucia: 好像不太有人长这样
Lucia: Doesn't seem like anyone looks like this.
Lucia:  嗯好像也不是呢
Shure: Hmm, it doesn't seem like it.
Jake: 把它弄一边长是吧
Jake: Make it one length, right?
Jake: 对那把它竖过来倒过来
Jake: Yeah, now turn it upright and flip it over.
Tasha: 就还剩最后的
Tasha: Only the last part is left.
Tasha: 这这两个也没找着家是吗对
Tasha: These two haven't found a place yet, right?
Tasha: 还剩最后5个找着家的
Tasha: Only five more to find a place.
Tasha: 要不尝试着把它们把这些放进去吧
Tasha: How about we try putting these in?
Tasha: 说不定形状就出来了
Jake: These shapes are coming out now.
Shure:  都行其实嗯
Shure: Anything works, actually.
Shure:  也别太长
Shure: Don't make it too long.
Shure:  别比那个黑板
Shure: Don't make it longer than the blackboard.
Lucia: 这怎么放能让他不不位移这样呗
Lucia: How can we place it so it doesn't move?
Shure:  这个还是高嗯
Shure: This is still high.
Jake: 这个高一点
Jake: This one is a bit high.
Shure:  再高一点点这个
Shure: A little higher, this one.
Shure:  啊过了
Shure: Ah, it's over.
Shure:  过了过了
Shure: It's over, it's over.
Shure:  OK OK好
Jake: OK, OK, good.
Shure:  yes
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  把它拼上对
Shure: Put it together, right.
Shure:  good good good
Shure: Good, good, good.
Alice: 这俩像在一块吗
Alice: Do these two look like they go together?
Shure:  人类的智慧
Shure: Human wisdom.
Tasha: 像又不太像
Tasha: They look similar but not quite.
Lucia: 这个好像
Lucia: This one looks like it.
Lucia: 是不是很像在一起啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look like they go together?
Lucia: 这俩嗯
Lucia: These two, hmm.
Lucia: 然后这个如果还在这的话就是这样
Lucia: And if this one is still here, it's like this.
Shure:  师傅你是干什么工作的
Shure: Master, what do you do for work?
Jake: 修空调了
Jake: I fix air conditioners.
Lucia: 接下来这里还缺一口
Lucia: There's still a piece missing here.
Shure:  先头先头按上去
Shure: Put the head on first.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 这个我就一个吗
Jake: Do I only have one of these?
Jake: 很短
Jake: It's very short, who is it?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  OK的OK
Shure: It's OK, OK.
Tasha: 我们已经越来越剧情真相了
Shure: We are getting closer to the truth of the story.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Yes, haha.
Tasha: 越来越有拼下去的动力了
Tasha: We're getting more motivated to continue.
Tasha: 还有3个人无家可归
Tasha: There are still 3 homeless people, not him.
Tasha: 这个感觉这个小家伙在哪都行
Tasha: It feels like this little guy can go anywhere.
Tasha: 所以他好像不能放在里面
Tasha: So it seems like he can't stay inside.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Jake: 纯手工
Jake: Purely handmade.
Lucia: 这如果有一个戳尖角的地方
Lucia: If there's a sharp corner here.
Lucia: 应该挺好的才对啊
Lucia: It should be pretty good, right?
Shure:  跟下面它是个六六边形的
Shure: It's a hexagon at the bottom.
Shure:  嗯你要找好那个
Shure: Hmm, you need to find that.
Alice:超过盘了哦
Alice: It's over the plate.
Lucia: 不行啊
Jake: No way, it's stuck.
Shure:  对卡死
Shure: Yeah, it's stuck.
Shure:  你先把那个螺母推进去
Shure: Push the nut in first.
Shure:  然后上面就可以搜卡进行下一半
Shure: Then you can move on to the next half.
Katrina:  看他只有一个
Katrina: Look, he only has one.
Katrina:  这个是吗
Katrina: Is this the one?
Lucia: 这个猫好像不在这里
Lucia: This cat seems to be not here.
Jake: 但是你可以把右边形给找着
Jake: But you can find the hexagon.
Lucia: 这造型会是什么呢
Lucia: What will this shape be?
Jake: 哎呀哎呀哎呀这啥呀
Jake: Oh my gosh, what is this?
Jake: 吓我一跳
Jake: Scared me.
Shure:  完了你给你给人家伙试试
Shure: You're done, let him try it.
Shure:  给人犯法
Jake: This is a crime.
Lucia: 那好像又不是真想要完全放进去
Lucia: He doesn't really want to put it in completely.
Tasha: 可是就是会有点边角的
Tasha: But there will be some edges.
Lucia:有没有可能
Tasha: I feel.
Lucia: 甜品
Lucia: Dessert.
Tasha: 这个是在这的吧
Tasha: This goes here, right?
Lucia: 哎是是是
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: Hehe.
Lucia: 那这个应该就不在
Lucia: Then this one shouldn't be here.
Lucia: 我感觉这个不对了
Lucia: I feel like this is wrong.
Tasha: 对这个不对
Tasha: Yeah, this is wrong.
Lucia: 塞进去了
Lucia: It's stuck in.
Tasha: 不对但这个肯定在这
Lucia: No, this must be here.
Lucia: 这个真的
Lucia: This really...
Lucia: 怎么看都有点像一个猫
Lucia: It kind of looks like a cat.
Lucia: 或者之类的东西
Lucia: Or something like that.
Tasha: 可能不清
Tasha: Maybe it's not clear.
Alice:这个头吗
Alice: This head?
Alice: 也不是
Alice: No, it's not.
Tasha: 嗯这是松
Tasha: Hmm, this is loose.
Alice: 不太像
Tasha: Maybe we can rehearse this in the wild.
Jake: 可以这是荒野去排练
Lucia: 无限尝试
Lucia: Endless attempts.
Tasha: 刚刚这个
小微 : 刚刚这个是归谁吗
Jake: Who did this belong to?
Alice: 这个不归谁
Tasha: This doesn't belong to anyone.
Katrina: 啊行
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done.
Alice: 哎对啊
Alice: Yeah, right.
Alice: 他们仨是归着的呀
Alice: The three of them belong together.
Tasha: 对对对他们仨是归着的
Tasha: Ah, yeah, yeah, the three of them belong together.
Lucia: 然后这还有一组这还有一组
Katrina: And then there's another group here, another group here.
Jake: 所以这个是干嘛的呀
Jake: So what's this for?
Jake: 这个这个有归家吗
Alice: Does this have a place?
Lucia: 刚才咱是不是他和熊猫也是女生
Lucia: Earlier, didn't he say the panda was a girl too?
Shure:  他是架黑板
Lucia: 不是他是蛇是蛇
Lucia: No, no, he said it was a snake.
Lucia: 那这个豹子
Lucia: Then what about the leopard?
Shure: 他俩应该不是不穿一起
Tasha: 这豹子这个平平的面很好找呀
Lucia: This leopard's flat face is easy to find.
Shure:  看图
Shure: Look at the picture.
Jake: 这是两边是吧
Katrina: Here, oh, there's a hexagon here.
Jake: 卡住了嗯
Jake: It's stuck, huh?
Jake: 不是这卡住的了
Jake: No, it's really stuck.
Lucia: 有没有可能豹子
Lucia: Is it possible the leopard...
Lucia: 在别的什么地方
Lucia: ...is somewhere else?
Jake: 不对
Jake: No, that's not right.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: Not here.
Katrina: 这俩人
Katrina: Those two.
Katrina:  干啥
Katrina: What's up?
Tasha: 是这样子的
Alice: What's going on here?
Tasha: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Hey, that's good, that's okay.
Jake: 我到那边试
Jake: I'll try over there.
Tasha: 只剩最后两个人
Tasha: Only two people left.
Tasha: 没有家可以归了
Tasha: Nowhere to go home.
Tasha: 然后我们就可以放到左边
Tasha: Then we can place it on the left.
Lucia: 他们有没有可能也是在边上的
Lucia: Could they also be on the side?
Lucia: 这一圈看着还挺像一个弧度的
Lucia: This circle looks like an arc.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 那这还直
Alice: But this is still straight.
Tasha: 这正好还差他一个边
Tasha: This just misses one edge.
Alice: 你说的那个平平的是不是这个
Alice: Is the flat part you're talking about this one?
Alice: 这可能不在那边
Alice: This might not be over there.
Lucia: 这个可能他是一个边
Lucia: This might be on one side.
Lucia: 跑了
Lucia: Ran away.
Lucia: 然后这个在这
Lucia: And then this goes here.
Lucia: 他们他们有点
Lucia: How should they confirm?
Lucia: 有点像边
Lucia: Kind of like an edge.
Lucia: 对他们有点像是一个边
Lucia: Yes, they are kind of like an edge.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 虽然不是100%确定
Lucia: Although it's not 100% certain.
Lucia: 有可能是这样的
Lucia: The height has been adjusted.
Tasha: 哎他们俩正好就这样子了
Tasha: Ah, they just ended up like this.
Tasha: OK了
Tasha: Hmm, it's okay now.
Tasha: 本来他们俩还分开了
Tasha: Initially, they were separated.
Jake: 比划比划要不
Jake: Why not give it a try?
Lucia: 哦原来这个牛
Lucia: Oh, so this cow...
Lucia: 底下这里是配它的
Lucia: 我就说这个地方应该很好
Lucia: I thought this place should be good.
Tasha: 刚刚找了半天
Tasha: Been looking for a while.
Tasha: 这人正好就找进去了
Tasha: This person just happened to find it.
Lucia: 歪打正着
Lucia: A lucky hit.
Tasha: 现在感觉把边整理整理
Tasha: Now it feels like tidying up the edges.
Tasha: 然后再把这几个组进去就行了
Tasha: Then just put these groups in.
Lucia: 这现在这些个边的顺序我们拼的
Lucia: 不一定是对的
Lucia: Not necessarily others.
Alice: 这个先拿出来一下
Tasha: 是不是这样子
Tasha: Is it like this?
Alice: 你觉得这个像不像边
Alice: Do you think this looks like an edge?
Jake: 这个会有卡的吗
Jake: Will this get stuck?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This...
Lucia: 也有一点
Lucia: Also a bit.
Lucia: 放进去试试
Lucia: Try putting it in.
Tasha: 我刚把哪个取出来来着
Tasha: Which one did I just take out?
Alice: 就这样是不像一个边
Alice: This doesn't look like an edge.
Alice: 哎对
Alice: Ah, right.
Alice: 也像一个边
Alice: It does look like an edge.
Lucia: 那这里需要卡吗
Lucia: Does it need to be stuck here?
Alice: 哎这个吗
Alice: Hey, is it this one?
Lucia: 哦有可能把他推过来
Lucia: Maybe push it over.
Alice: 哎拼上了哦
Alice: Ah, it fits now.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Lucia: 我刚找到了
Lucia: I just found it.
Shure:  哎智慧
Shure: Oh, wisdom.
Jake: 智慧在哪
Jake: Where's wisdom?
Tasha: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Lucia: 我刚刚哦这样接近真相了啊这
Lucia: I was so close to the truth just now.
Tasha: 3个都是怎么拼来着
Tasha: How did you fit all three?
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Tasha: 就这样啊
Tasha: Just like this?
Shure:  下面那个
Shure: The one below.
Tasha: 然后像
Katrina: Then the bottom is very proper.
Tasha: 像像挨着这个的
Katrina: Like, next to this.
Jake: 感觉
Tasha: It definitely feels like it.
Shure:  必然
Tasha: 就这个地方
Tasha: Just this spot.
Lucia: 挨着这里挨着这里
Lucia: Close to here, close to here.
Lucia: 呃，推一下这里
Lucia: Uh, push this spot.
Alice:他俩拼到了
Alice: They got it together.
Alice:好好好好好
Lucia: They got it together.
Tasha: 哎呀，刚刚那个呢
Lucia: Oh, where's that one?
Lucia: 真相只有一个
Tasha: Okay, okay, there's only one truth.
Tasha: 啊，我，我
Lucia: Ah, I, I...
Lucia: 再往好像再往这里推一点点
Lucia: Push it a little more this way.
Lucia: 就是往这个方向推一点点
Lucia: Just push it a little in this direction.
Lucia: 哎再往上往下
Lucia: Hey, up or down?
Lucia: 就是
Jake: Just down.
Lucia: 这好像还挺像的
Lucia: This looks quite similar.
Tasha: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Alice: 好，就这动物
Shure:  太牛了
Shure: Awesome, we got this side done.
Lucia: 接下来的这一边
Lucia: Now for this side
杨硕：拼好了
Yang Shuo: It's all assembled
Shure:  这黑板可还行
Shure: This blackboard is alright
Jake: 确实有黑板
Jake: There really is a blackboard
Jake: 他背面就是黑板
Jake: The back side is the blackboard
Jake: 他俩是一
Jake: They are one piece
Alice:他俩他俩是一家的
Jake: 是的他送来几个粉笔
Jake: Yes, he sent some chalk
Lucia: 哦这样子的
Lucia: Oh, I see
Jake: 这个还能凑一点
Jake: We can still piece this together
Tasha: 他们是这样子的
Tasha: They're like this
Tasha: 弧形
Tasha: Curved, right
Lucia: 有没有可能呢
Lucia: Is it possible?
Lucia: 角度好像稍微有点卡住了
Lucia: The angle seems a bit stuck
Jake: 放哪了太牛了
Jake: Where did you put it? Amazing
Jake: 放这边了
Jake: Put it here
Lucia: 有点像
Lucia: It looks a bit like it
Lucia: 但怎么感觉好像不完全对似的
Lucia: But it doesn't seem quite right
Tasha: 因为这还有这么大块呢
Tasha: Because there's still a big piece here
Tasha: 对我感觉会这么一大块
Tasha: Yes, I think it will be a big piece
Tasha: 蘑菇味
Tasha: Mushroom flavor, they should all be like this
Lucia: 这一块这么不规则
Lucia: This piece is so irregular
Lucia: 他应该是在中间的吧
Lucia: It should be in the middle, right?
Lucia: 嗯他会在哪
Lucia: Hmm, where would it go
Tasha: 我把它先取出来
Lucia: I'll take it out first
Lucia: 哎有点像那个地方啊
Lucia: Oh, it looks like that spot
Shure:  our whiteboard
Lucia: our whiteboard
Lucia: 好像也不是
Lucia: Maybe not
Tasha: 先把他放进去吧
Tasha: Let's put it in first
Lucia: 哎好像可以可以可以
Lucia: Oh, it seems like it fits, it fits
Alice:在这
Lucia: 对好像可以
Lucia: Yes, it seems like it fits
Lucia: 哎但这样的话
Lucia: But if that's the case
Lucia: 这里好像又拼不上了
Lucia: Then this part doesn't fit together
Lucia: 但这两个肯定是挨着
Lucia: But these two are definitely next to each other
Lucia: 可是没事
Lucia: But it's okay
Alice: 这个边不一定在这
Alice: This edge might not be here
Alice: 把这个边先拿出来
Alice: Take this edge out first
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: 那就把那个牛和那个啥放一起
Alice:对
Lucia: 然后这个是在
Lucia: 但这个好像是在它的上面
Lucia: 这样子的
Tasha: 然后这里在一个
Tasha: 这个边也不一定对对
Lucia: 对这个边的位置
Lucia: 这个边不一定对
Tasha: 可是这个边这样写是一对的呀
Lucia: 对这应该是对的
Lucia: 就这这一圈应该是对的
Tasha: 连到这都是对的
Tasha: 只有这个边和这个边
Lucia: 好奇怪
Alice:要不
Alice:先把这个不确定的边先给他拿出来
Jake:好帮我整两杯
Jake:我们一起整两杯
Alice:嗯等一下呦
Lucia: 有谁有脚吗
Lucia: 这个突出来的
Katrina: The upstairs isn't ventilated
Alice: 你知道咋拼来着
Lucia: Do you know how to spell it?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice: 现在脑子有点转不动
Alice: My brain is a bit stuck now.
Lucia: 是的但这个其实也还蛮像的
Lucia: Yes, but this actually looks quite similar.
Alice: 这俩咋拼来着
Tasha: 这个和谁是一家来着
Tasha:  这个
Lucia: 这个这个和和他们吧
Lucia: 嗯哎
Tasha: 等等他是和谁
Lucia: 对对他和这个
Lucia: 他和这个鹰
Lucia: 我记得是在鹰翅膀的某一个地方
Lucia: 可能是这这这啊嗯
Lucia: 对的对的
Lucia: 然后这样子哎
Alice: 哎这个咋拼来着
Alice: Hey, how do you spell this?
Alice: 怎么一会拼着拼着拼
Alice: Why does it get confusing after a while?
Alice:拼迷了
Alice: I'm getting puzzled.
Alice:嗯对
Lucia: 就这个半圆
Lucia: 怎么还缺一部分呢
Tasha: 天呐
Tasha: 这放哪来着
Alice:哎呀一会都拼迷了
Tasha: 哦哦找到了
Tasha: Oh oh, found it.
Lucia: 找到了找到了
Lucia: Found it, found it.
Tasha: 哇我们仨是天才
Tasha: Wow, the three of us are geniuses.
Lucia: 哎哎哎这这几个刚才是怎么
Tasha: What if we decorate the second floor?
Lucia: 这样的是吗
Tasha: 对对对
Lucia: 然后这还有一个
嗯嗯
Lucia:  怎么还少一块啊
Jake: Is the chair one piece?
Lucia: 咋回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Tasha: 少一块
Alice:会不会是它
Katrina: It's just the product.
Alice:OK
Alice:只要把它放进去就行了
Lucia: 胜利近在眼前
Katrina: Victory is within sight.
Lucia: 这个地方是不是在这里啊
Lucia: Is this place supposed to be here?
Lucia: 那就不不太一样
Lucia: Then it's not quite the same.
Lucia: 不完全一样
Lucia: Not exactly the same.
Lucia: 他就那边大一些啊
Lucia: It's a bit bigger over there.
Lucia: 又散了
Lucia: There you go, your voice is trembling again.
Alice:你颤音了
Tasha: 崩溃了
Tasha: I'm breaking down.
Lucia: 收集一些拼图数据可还行
Lucia: Collecting some puzzle data is quite okay.
Tasha: 让AI知道
Tasha: Let AI know.
Lucia: 快了快了
Lucia: Almost done, almost done.
Alice: 这俩咋拼的
Alice: How do these two fit together?
Lucia: 我们现在可以整体根据这个形状
Lucia: Now we can look at the overall shape.
Lucia: 来看一看
Lucia: Let's take a look.
Alice: 是不在这啊
Alice: 哇天才
Alice: Wow, genius!
Lucia: 可以可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay.
Alice: 天才
Lucia: 对的对的
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Alice: 来
Lucia: Come on.
Lucia: 那我觉得那个鹰翅膀就是在这里
Tasha: 放进去放进去放进去
Lucia: 我觉得鹰翅膀就是在这里
Lucia: I think the eagle wing should go here.
Lucia: 稍等，我们比划比划
Lucia: Hold on, let's measure it.
Tasha: 如果鹰翅膀放在这里的话哎
Tasha: If the eagle wing goes here, hmm...
Tasha: 屁股就撅在这是吧
Tasha: The tail will stick out here, right?
Lucia: 对这屁股应该是在这个地方吧
Lucia: Yes, the tail should be in this spot.
Lucia: 啊对对对对屁股就在这
Lucia: 然后鹰翅放在这啊
Lucia: And then the wing goes here.
Alice:蛇蛇在这呢
Lucia: 哇太不容易了
Lucia: 对的对的
Lucia: 然后这个
Lucia: 这个松鼠好像是在在鹰翅膀这里
Lucia: 哈哈哈不行
Lucia: Hahaha, no way.
Alice: 这个要最后放
Alice: This one goes last.
Lucia: 因为他哪都可以
Alice: Hahaha, because it fits anywhere.
Lucia: 怕他嘛
Lucia: Are you scared? Come on.
Alice: 我们见证奇迹的时刻
Alice: It's time to witness a miracle.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈太难了
Alice: Hahaha, it's so hard.
Alice: 来我们录一下这个数据
Alice: Let's record this data.
Alice: 好你来
Alice: Okay, you do it.
Jake: 咖啡味已经出来了呢
Jake: The coffee flavor is coming out.
Lucia: 快快快这可是人类早期
Jake: Hurry, hurry, this is early human...
Lucia: 好不容易拼出拼图的珍贵数据
Lucia: Rare data from completing a puzzle.
Alice:快来快来
Lucia: 快来快来
Lucia: Come on, come on.
Lucia: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: 拼好了哈哈哈
Jake: It's done, hahaha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh, haha.
Jake: 好强啊
Jake: So strong, I'm exhausted.
Alice:累死了
Jake:哇靠
Lucia: It was so hard, oh my god.
Lucia: 太不容易了
Jake: 太强了
Jake: So strong.
Alice: 累的要命
Jake: 用了多久
Jake: How long did it take?
Alice: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know how long.
Jake: 应该半个多小时
Jake: Probably over half an hour.
Katrina:  所以土地公公在哪
Katrina: So where is the Earth God?
Lucia: 哪个土地公公这啊
Lucia: Which Earth God is this?
Lucia: 他就在边上哈哈
Lucia: He's right there, haha.
Jake: 这个到时候秀给客人
Jake: We'll show this to the guests later.
Jake: 这个还有点脸面
Jake: This has some face value.
Jake: 哼这我们拼好了
Jake: Hmph, we finished this.
Jake: 然后你们再来拼
Jake: Then you guys can do it too.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 他上面是不是还有
Lucia: Is there more on top?
Lucia: 一个一个笋就这样子卡住了
Lucia: One bamboo shoot is stuck like this.
Alice:没了就这俩
Lucia: It should be just this face.
Alice: 啊，那
Alice: Ah, then...
Jake:这个也可以研究一会
Jake: We can study this for a while.
Jake: 那这个是不是可以那
Jake: So can we do this?
Lucia: 那那是他俩互相
Lucia: They can pinch each other a bit.
Lucia: 哎呦哎呦小心小心别撒了
Lucia: Oh, careful, careful, don't spill it.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:放平吧要不就
Shure: Place it flat, otherwise it won't be good.
Lucia: 对然后就这样子夹住
Lucia: Yes, just clip it like this.
Katrina:  稳定的三角形结构
Katrina: A stable triangular structure.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 为了防止它洒
Lucia: 这样挡一下感觉
Lucia: Block it like this, it feels secure.
Lucia: 对这样就不容易块就不容易掉出来
Lucia: Yes, this way it won't fall out easily.
Lucia: 哎把这一边朝着另外那一边
Alice: Yes, push this side to the other side.
Alice:换一下
Alice:恩恩恩
Alice: 好呀哈哈
Alice: Sure, haha.
Lucia: 小心哈哈
Lucia: Careful, haha.
Alice: 土地公掉了不该冒这个险
Alice: The Earth God fell, shouldn't take this risk.
Alice: 好的这次我不冒险
Alice: Okay, I won't take risks this time.
Lucia: 哎这个拼好蛮好看的
Lucia: Wow, this looks nice after assembling.
Lucia: 就不知为何
Lucia: Just don't know why...
Lucia: 有种日本服饰会的那种 画风的感觉
Lucia: It has a Japanese aesthetic vibe.
Lucia: 啊哈哈
Lucia: Ah, haha.
Alice: 这样耶头挤着屁股的这种
Alice: Like this, heads squeezing against butts.
Alice: 和谐相处
Alice: Living in harmony.
Jake:看一看有多和谐
Alice: Haha, see how harmonious it is.
Alice: 和谐吗
Alice: Harmonious, right?
Lucia: 就在我们的这个地球上
Lucia: Right here on our planet
Lucia: 和谐共处
Lucia: Coexisting in harmony
Jake:熊猫后面他很开心的感觉
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake:这个表情
Jake:我觉得真不容易
Jake: 哈哈哈看得出来了
Lucia: 尝试了好长时间
Lucia: Tried for a long time
Lucia: 因为他每个字就是这一些
Lucia: Because every word he says is just this
Jake:这一些你们怎么拼接来的
Alice:这个就是找那种
Alice:你看像这种比较紧密的
Alice: 哦哦就先拼起来
Alice: Oh, just piece it together first
Alice: 然后大块大块大块的看
Alice: Then look at the big pieces
Alice: 最后大块怎么拼起来
Alice: Finally, how to put the big pieces together
Jake: 我看上面的可能还好一点
Jake: Yeah, I think the top part might be a bit easier
Alice: 对就这种还好一点
Tasha: Yeah, just find the edges
Alice: 对对对就是差不多最后拼起来
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, almost there, just put it together
Jake: 这个边缘确实还挺圆的
Jake: This edge is actually quite round
Lucia: 嗯除了这一块但是后面就是这
Lucia: Except for this part, but later on...
Lucia: 这部分拼好之后
Lucia: After we piece this part together
Lucia: 我们就发现他这个弧度很像是这个圆
Lucia: We realized this curve looks like this circle
Lucia: 所以就还是放在边上
Lucia: So we still put it on the side
Jake: 你看一下
Lucia: Oh, take a look
Alice: 一开始这个就不在这个弧的考虑范围
Alice: At first, this wasn't even considered part of the curve
Lucia: 对嗯对障眼法
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, an optical illusion
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive
Alice: 累死的路啊
Alice: An exhausting path
Lucia: 好有成就感啊
Lucia: So fulfilling
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 我不敢想象
Tasha: I can't imagine
Tasha: 如果后面客人来玩这
Tasha: If guests come to play this later
Tasha: 玩一个小时会不会想走
Tasha: Play for an hour, will they want to leave?
Tasha: 哈哈哈客人可能拼一拼就
Tasha: Haha, guests might just try a bit and...
Lucia: 哎呀不拼了我们要下一个节目哈哈
Lucia: Ah, forget it, let's move on to the next activity, haha
Jake: 我们琢磨琢磨
Jake: Let's think about it
Jake: 这个要要不看看你的开箱
Jake: How about we check out your unboxing
Tasha: 我的开箱啊
Tasha: My unboxing?
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Jake:你有好的东西要不给我们秀一秀
Jake: You have good stuff, why don't you show us?
Lucia: 哎我的刚才
Lucia: Oh, mine just now...
Tasha: 不用吧Lucia: 哦在这
Tasha: No need, Lucia: Oh, here it is
Tasha: 不用秀蛋糕的模具
Jake: No need to show the cake mold
Tasha: 4寸和6寸的
Tasha: 4-inch and 6-inch ones.
Alice:打蛋器
Tasha: 打蛋器搅拌棒
Jake: 太专业了
Jake: So professional.
Tasha: 裱花嘴
Tasha: Piping tips.
Tasha: 薄脆
Tasha: Crisps.
Tasha: 刮板
Tasha: Scraper.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Alice: 刮板
Jake: Scraper, scraper, oh oh oh.
Tasha: 啊也可以平的也可以切面团
Tasha: Ah, it can be flat or used to cut dough.
Jake: 明白明白
Tasha: Got it, got it.
Tasha: 这个想的是做
Tasha: This one is for making...
Alice: 杯子的那种对
Alice: For cups, right?
Lucia: 纸杯甜点那种吗
Lucia: Like for cupcakes?
Alice: 饮料应该也行
Lucia: Yeah, it should work for drinks too.
Jake: 30306090120是吧一盒30 卖的话是吗
Jake: 30, 60, 90, 120, right? A box of 30 for selling, right?
Jake: 对定价多少钱
Jake: Yeah, what's the price?
Tasha: 定价啊定价一般1515
Tasha: The price, the price is generally 15, 15.
Alice:紫薯粉
Tasha: 这个是送的哦
Tasha: 15, this one is a gift.
Tasha: 吉利丁粉
Tasha: Gelatin powder.
Katrina:  啊凝固用的
Katrina: Ah, for solidifying.
Tasha: 你要最量
Tasha: You need the most.
Shure:  咱们纸抽在哪
Tasha: Where are the tissues?
Jake: 呃这边怎么了
Jake: Uh, over here. Wipe and wash, what's up?
Shure:  摆摆桌子上养的让娃找纸找不到
Shure: Put them on the table, the kid can't find them.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Alice: 哎我们的拼图呢
Alice: Hey, where's our puzzle?
Lucia: 在这里
Katrina: It's here.
Lucia: 幸好外面有一层
Jake: Oh, luckily there's a layer outside.
Alice: 来欣赏
Alice: Let's appreciate it.
Jake: 摇起来
Jake: Shake it up.
Alice: 电子秤
Alice: Electronic scale.
Tasha: 还有的袋子呢
Tasha: Where are the other bags?
Jake: 这边有很多
Jake: There are many here.
Jake: 是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Tasha: 呃这些对吧
Tasha: Uh, these, right?
Tasha: 用
Tasha: Use.
Tasha: 纸杯
Tasha: Cupcake liners.
Tasha: Paper cups.
Tasha: 呃量温度的
Tasha: Uh, to measure temperature.
Jake: 烤箱在哪
Jake: Where's the oven?
Jake: 打蛋器
Jake: Where's the egg beater?
Jake: 那我们放哪呢
Jake: So where should we put it?
Jake: 我放哪比较合适
Jake: Where's the best place to put it?
Jake: 削皮刀哪
Jake: Where's the peeler?
Tasha: 放这呗这我觉得应该放烤箱上面
Jake: Let's put it here. I think it should go on top of the oven.
Tasha: 呃微波炉上面会比较合适
Tasha: Uh, it would be better on top of the microwave.
Shure:  咱这边只有微波炉
Shure: We only have a microwave here.
Jake: 你买烤箱了
Jake: Did you buy an oven?
Tasha: 烤箱温度计
Jake: A thermometer, an oven thermometer.
Alice: 黑巧吗
Jake: White cake, dark chocolate?
Tasha: 对黑巧做那种熔浆蛋糕
Tasha: Yeah, dark chocolate for that molten cake.
Katrina:  好专业
Katrina: So professional, that tiramisu fork.
Alice: 对对对提拉米苏的叉
Alice: Yeah, yeah, the tiramisu fork.
Tasha: 还有提拉米苏的盒子哪呢
Tasha: Where's the tiramisu box?
Tasha: 嗯这伯爵红茶包
Tasha: Hmm, the Earl Grey tea bags and these things.
Jake: 西昨天应该都扫一遍
Jake: We should have cleaned everything yesterday.
Jake: 扫一天
Tasha: 可可粉
Tasha: 这个是那个咖啡酒
Tasha: This is that coffee liqueur.
Alice:色素吗
Katrina:  你会调酒吗
Jake: Do you know how to mix drinks?
Shure:  我啊嗯
Shure: Me? Uh, yeah.
Jake: 看起来科一会
Jake: Looks like you know a bit.
Jake: 哈哈哈看一下
Jake: Haha, let's see.
Lucia: 最最简单的
Lucia: The simplest.
Lucia: 买一瓶威士忌
Lucia: Buy a bottle of whiskey.
Lucia: 买买几瓶可乐
Lucia: And a few bottles of Coke.
Lucia: 然后兑一块就完事了
Lucia: Then just mix them together.
Katrina:  咱有多少个杯子呀
Katrina: How many cups do we have?
Katrina:  有20个杯
Katrina: We have 20 cups.
Shure:  有上面6个下面6个12个
Jake: 我靠这什么
Jake: Oh my, what is this?
Jake: 架上去吧
Jake: Put it up there.
Shure:  咱们经费这么充足吗
Shure: Do we have such a big budget?
Shure:  我感觉我是不是应该花花呀
Shure: I feel like I should spend it.
Katrina: 咱都是他的助手
Jake: 对这边主要花了
Jake: Yes, we mainly spent it here.
Jake: 花了很有用的很多费用
Jake: Spent a lot on very useful stuff.
Jake:非常有用
Tasha: 买点柠檬片
Katrina:  我来记一下
Katrina: I'll write it down.
Lucia: 啊对我也要买柠檬
Lucia: Oh right, I need to buy lemons too.
Jake: 嗯下午要买东西就记一下菜单吧
Tasha: Yeah, if we're buying things in the afternoon, let's make a list.
Jake: 或者单写写在这个白板上面
Jake: Or just write it on this whiteboard.
Jake: 这个白板现在你们都可以写吧
Jake: You can all write on this whiteboard, right?
Jake: 比较好写
Jake: It's easy to write on.
Shure:  这白板拍一下拍
Shure: Let's take a picture of this whiteboard.
Jake: 拍完了
Jake: Take a picture and then erase it.
Jake: 再拍一下擦掉吧
Jake: Take another picture and erase it.
Jake: 都可以调监控的
Jake: You can check the recordings.
Lucia: 哦那个手指饼干
Lucia: Oh, those finger biscuits.
Jake: 对就这么拍你
Lucia: Yeah, just take a picture like that.
Tasha: 淀粉肉松
Shure:  哈哈哈哇真的好赛博呀
Shure: Hahaha, wow, this is so cyber.
Shure:  看一眼我拍完你的
Shure: Look at this, I took a picture of you.
Jake:我记住你了
Shure: Hahaha, Jake: I remember you now.
Tasha: 但这家特别贵
Tasha: But this place is really expensive.
Tasha: 还好经费充足
Tasha: Good thing we have a big budget.
Alice:哇
Katrina: Wow, look at this.
Alice: 大手套
Alice: With a big budget, we can buy some drinks too.
Shure:  这啥呀酒
Shure: What's this? Alcohol?
Jake: 很多酒
Jake: Lots of alcohol.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Do you want any sauce?
Alice:沙拉酱吗
Tasha: 切蛋糕胚的
Tasha: For cutting cake layers.
Tasha: 还有固定器然后
Shure: And this ice.
Lucia: 这个怎么用啊
Katrina: How do you use this?
Tasha: 就是你把这个固定器这
Tasha: I mean, did you freeze this fixture or just refrigerate it?
Tasha: 比如说你不是切了一个蛋糕了吗
Tasha: Like, you cut a cake, right?
Jake: 其实也可以
Tasha: Actually, you can.
Tasha: 然后就把这两个固定就固定在第几层
Alice: And then fix these two, fix them on which layer?
Tasha: 然后呢用这个刀
Tasha: And then use this knife to cut across horizontally.
Alice:这样横着过去
Tasha: 对然后他就会切出来很平整的面
Alice: Yeah, then it will cut out a very smooth surface.
Alice:对
Jake: 哎不是再往下一个
Tasha: No, not that, one layer down.
Shure:  哦那不是平格
Shure: Oh, that's not level.
Alice: 换手套吗
Alice: Change gloves?
Tasha: 无菌手套
Tasha: Sterile gloves.
Shure:  外卖买那边也没多少
Shure: Not much from the takeout side either.
Tasha: 黄豆粉
Tasha: Soybean powder.
Katrina:  嗯嗯养乐多
Katrina: Mm-hmm, Yakult.
Tasha: 糯米粉
Tasha: Mm, glutinous rice flour.
Tasha: 两个勺没了
Tasha: Two scoops and it's all gone.
Lucia: 好丰盛的材料
Lucia: Such a rich spread of ingredients.
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh my!
Katrina:  伏特加
Katrina: Vodka.
Lucia: 这边挪一点
Lucia: Move this a bit.
Lucia: 这个是我的
Lucia: This one's mine.
Lucia: 我的眼镜盒
Lucia: My glasses case.
Lucia: 哎这个水是
Alice:没开的吧
Lucia: 没开的那我可以开一瓶吗
Lucia: If it's not, can I open a bottle?
Lucia: 啊这瓶开过了
Lucia: Ah, this one’s been opened.
Lucia: 有点渴
Jake: I'm a bit thirsty.
Lucia: 这瓶好像没开过
Lucia: This one seems unopened.
Jake: 这瓶没开过
Lucia: This one's unopened. This one's unopened.
Jake: 要不贴个名字吧
Jake: How about we label them?
Jake: 有那个小贴纸
Jake: We have those small stickers.
Jake: 有道理还在吗
Jake: Makes sense, are they still around?
Jake: 嗯找不着了
Jake: Hmm, can’t find them.
Alice: 你可以在这折个角
Alice: You can fold the corner here.
Lucia: 有道理
Katrina: Makes sense.
Lucia: 但是如果大家都折了一个角的话
Katrina: But if everyone folds a corner...
Alice: 不一样的角
Alice: Different corners.
Jake: 那那能记住哈
Jake: OK, that way you can remember.
Alice: 过来有个人是一个撕掉
Alice: Someone will come by and tear one off.
Jake: 写一下吧
Jake: Just write it down.
Lucia: 我把外面就撕下来
Katrina: I'll just tear off the outer part.
Lucia: 给他叠个花
Katrina: And fold it into a flower.
Jake: 就在这写个肩吧
Jake: Just write it on the shoulder here.
Alice: 找不到啊
Tasha: If you go back to the dorm now, you won't find it.
Jake: 你还要画哦
Jake: You still need to draw it.
Lucia: 笔在这里
Jake: The pen is here.
Lucia: 我先简单在这个白的地方画一道
Lucia: I'll just simply draw a line on this white part.
Alice: 画一道
Shure: Draw a line, alright.
Katrina:  你们毕设这么早吗
Katrina: You guys are doing your project this early?
Shure:  我们还有个模拟答辩
Shure: We still have a mock defense.
Shure:  很奇怪啊
Shure: It's kinda weird.
Lucia: 你们还有模拟答辩
Lucia: You guys still have a mock defense?
Katrina:  论文还没写
Katrina: I haven't even written my thesis.
Shure:  哦你是软件工程的是吧
Shure: Oh, you're in software engineering, right?
Shure:  嗯好
Shure: Got it.
Shure:  帮我改改代码吧
Shure: Help me with my code?
Shure:  到时候哈哈哈
Shure: Later, haha.
Katrina:  帮你改代码
Katrina: Help you with your code?
Katrina:  我自己代码还没跑完呢
Katrina: I haven't even finished mine.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure:  太爽了
Shure: This is awesome.
Shure:  出去搞杯咖啡喝
Shure: Let's go grab a coffee.
Shure:  在外面坐一坐晒晒太阳
Shure: Sit outside and enjoy the sun.
Shure:  无敌了
Shure: Unbeatable.
Jake: 点外卖吗
Jake: Ordering takeout?
Tasha: 还没吃午饭吗
Jake: Lunch, anyone?
Lucia: 对，现在几点了
Lucia: Not hungry at all.
Jake: 一点不饿是吧
Jake: Not hungry, huh?
Jake: 对我们再录40分钟就结束了这一轮
Jake: Alright, we'll record for another 40 minutes and then wrap up this round.
Jake: 然后40分钟能干嘛呢
Jake: So, what can we do in 40 minutes?
Jake: 点个外卖
Jake: Order some takeout.
Jake: 就是有40分钟外卖差不多能到吧
Jake: So, the takeout should arrive in about 40 minutes, right?
Jake: 对吧可以现在点一下
Jake: Right? We can order now.
Jake: 然后大概准备一下下午买点啥
Jake: And then maybe prepare a bit for the afternoon, decide what to buy.
Jake: 在这写一写
Jake: Write it down here.
Jake: 拉倒了做东西
Jake: Forget it, make some stuff.
Tasha: 就是在一楼做是吗
Tasha: Are we doing it on the first floor?
Jake: 在一楼做
Jake: On the first floor.
Tasha: 哦我就是问问
Jake: Oh, I was just asking.
Jake: 对在一楼做
Jake: Yes, on the first floor.
Jake: 然后在这摆这个
Jake: Then set this up here.
Jake: 这个就当就是工作台
Jake: This will be the workstation.
Alice:工作台
Lucia: 工作台工作台
Lucia: Workstation, workstation.
Jake: 和甜点的那个台子放在也是这边是吧
Jake: And the dessert table goes here too, right?
Jake: 对
Shure: Yeah, okay.
Shure:  不是就是他
Shure: No, it's just him.
Jake: 对是
Shure: Yes, it is.
Jake: 这就是一个厨房
Jake: This is a kitchen.
Shure:  全是礼物
Shure: All gifts.
Tasha: 谢谢
Shure: Thanks, all...
Alice: 全开放的
Alice: It's all open.
Jake: 这边是会议室和厨房合理吧
Jake: This area will be the meeting room and kitchen, makes sense?
Shure:  我也带稍微带一点
Shure: I'll also bring a bit more.
Tasha: 把所有的模具都放到这个袋子里
Tasha: Put all the molds in this bag.
Shure:  开飞机就要很大的钱
Shure: Flying a plane costs a lot of money.
Lucia: 这个哦哦这是
Lucia: This, oh, this is...
Lucia: 这是某位同学的眼镜
Lucia: These are someone's glasses.
Lucia: 我还以为是我们戴的这个像了是的
Lucia: I thought they were ours, they look so similar. Shure: Yes.
Alice:普通眼镜
Shure:  混淆你们用的
Shure: Confusing with yours.
Jake: 我这个擦掉了
Jake: I'll erase this.
Jake: 你们想写就写
Jake: Write if you want to.
Lucia: 眼镜中混入了一个叛徒
Lucia: A traitor among the glasses.
Shure:  AI中混住了一个傻子哈哈哈
Shure: An idiot mixed in with the AI, hahaha.
Lucia: 哎这个白板没有背面吗
Lucia: Hey, doesn't this whiteboard have a back side?
Tasha: 只有一面
Lucia: Only one side has a back?
Jake: 背面是个黑板
Jake: The back is a blackboard, OK.
Jake: 对可以用粉笔写啊
Jake: Yeah, you can use chalk on it.
Jake: 他还给红笔
Jake: It even comes with a red pen.
Lucia: 原来是这样的设计
Lucia: Oh, that's the design.
Tasha: 对这个是这备用的一套是吗
Lucia: So this is a spare set, right?
Lucia: 没有是吧
Lucia: No, it's not?
Lucia: 就是那个
Lucia: Just that one.
Lucia: 这个刀拿开是吗
Lucia: Should I move the knife?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh, be careful with your hand!
Lucia: 这个挺利的
Lucia: This is pretty sharp.
Lucia: 我们家好像拿这个打过
Lucia: I think we used this at home before.
Lucia: 果汁之类的东西
Lucia: To make juice or something.
Jake: 要不整点咖啡
Jake: How about making some coffee?
Jake: 咖啡整整好了是吧
Jake: The coffee turned out pretty good, right?
Jake: 啊咖啡整好了
Jake: Ah, the coffee is ready.
Shure:  咖啡好像没有那么多
Jake: Looks like we don't have much coffee.
Shure:  而且只只能手冲
Jake: Oh, and we can only make pour-over coffee.
Jake: 那每人喝一口吧
Jake: Let's all just have a sip then.
Jake: 哈哈哈一小杯就是one shot的啊
Jake:one shot咖啡
Shure: OK, warm smile coffee.
Shure:  咖啡也按shot喝是吧
Shure:  对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  直接shot浓缩
Lucia: 我我刚开始点是不会点
Shure: Haha, yeah, I didn't know how to order at first.
Lucia: 真的点过one shot
Lucia: 浓缩上来的时候我都惊呆了
Lucia: When the concentrate came, I was shocked.
Lucia: 可以嗯啊这是点咖啡
Lucia: I thought, hmm, is this how you order coffee?
Lucia: 我刚开始不会点
Lucia: I didn't know how to order at first.
Lucia: 然后就是点过那种纯的espresso就一shot
Lucia: So I ordered a pure espresso, just one shot.
Lucia: 然后上来我真的惊呆了
Lucia: When it came, I was really shocked.
Lucia: 这怎么喝
Lucia: How do you drink this?
Shure:  哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, it's good.
Shure:  我们现在开始中午饭
Shure: Let's start lunch now.
Jake: 午饭点外卖
Jake: Let's order takeout for lunch.
Jake: 外卖点什么呢
Jake: What should we order?
Jake: 看一看
Shure: 吃的点什么
Shure: Let's see what we can eat.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  美团外卖美团外卖送啥都快
Jake: Meituan delivery, Meituan delivery, they deliver everything fast.
Lucia: 呃那个是干嘛的呀
Lucia: Uh, what is that for?
Lucia: 就是就是用来放它的吗
Lucia: Is it just to hold it in place?
Alice: 要不然它会跑
Lucia: Yeah, the mat, otherwise it will run away. Oh, okay, got it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈他是用来干嘛的
Lucia: Hahaha, what is it used for?
Alice: 做他的lunch
Katrina: 我记一下我要买啥
Shure: Should I write down what I want to buy?
Jake: 报个菜名
Jake: Name a dish.
Jake: 吃我请您吃
Jake: I'll treat you to something.
Shure:  我请大家吃
Shure: I'll treat everyone.
Shure:  何帆不认识饭
Shure: He Fan doesn't know rice.
Shure:  牛肉饭加锅炉
Shure: Beef rice with boiler.
Shure:  小锅牛肉吉野家
Shure: Small pot beef Yoshinoya.
Shure:  肯德基宅基送聚德
Shure: KFC delivery.
Shure:  上北京烤鸭老街春饼
Shure: Peking duck from Old Street Spring Pancake.
Shure:  南城香饭香串香馄饨香
Shure: South City Fragrant Rice, Fragrant Skewers, Fragrant Wontons.
Shure:  小栋酿猪脚饭
Shure: Small Dong's Braised Pork Rice.
Shure:  酱骨饭汉堡王本味龙江猪脚饭
Shure: Braised bone rice, Burger King, Benwei Longjiang Braised Pork Rice.
Shure:  人民公社大食堂神话烤鱼
Shure: People's Commune Canteen, Mythical Grilled Fish.
Shure:  便益坊烤鸭河间驴肉火烧
Shure: Bianyifang Peking Duck, Hejian Donkey Meat Sandwich.
Shure:  河谷烧
Shure: He Gu Grill.
Shure:  日料寿司田老师红烧肉张记京味卤煮
Shure: Japanese food sushi, Teacher Tian's Braised Pork, Zhang Ji Beijing Flavor Stew.
Shure:  哈哈哈行是吧
Shure: Hahaha, enough, right?
Shure:  他们肯定一个都没记住
Shure: They definitely didn't remember any of that.
Shure:  哈哈哈自己都没记住
Shure: Hahaha, I didn't even remember it myself.
Lucia: 我就听到一个KFC
Jake: I only heard KFC.
Jake: 好那就KFC吧怎么样
Jake: Okay, then KFC, how about that?
Lucia: 不不不我只是只记得这个
Jake: No, no, I just remembered that one.
Lucia: 因为太快了
Jake: Because it was too fast.
Shure:  汉堡王啊
Jake: Burger King, huh?
Jake: 可以就就肯德基
Jake: Burgers are fine, just KFC.
Jake: 就KFC给外国人一些小震撼
Jake: Just KFC to give the foreigners a little surprise.
Lucia: 我我没有忌口
Jake: Okay, Lucia: I don't have any dietary restrictions.
Lucia: 所以大家吃什么都行
Lucia: So everyone can eat whatever they want.
Lucia: 我都可以疯了
Tasha: 好那就厨具我们都拆一下嘛
Jake: Alright, let's unpack all the kitchen utensils.
Jake: KFC
Shure: KFC KFC Family Bucket.
Jake: 呃有些新品
Jake: Uh, there are some new items.
Jake: 热辣不羁全是肉
Jake: Spicy and all meat.
Jake: 尊享无敌披萨
Jake: Supreme unbeatable pizza.
Alice: 用之前记得刷一遍 好脏啊感觉
Jake: 下面全是肉的披萨
Jake: The bottom is all meat pizza.
Jake: 炸鸡炸鸡为对
Jake: Fried chicken, fried chicken is correct.
Jake: 炸鸡是面皮的
Jake: The fried chicken has a crust.
Jake: 这个披萨
Jake: This pizza.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 衣服没裹上我就先把这个再拔下来了
Jake: The clothes aren't wrapped up, I'll just take this off first.
Lucia: 这样我就可以自由活动
Lucia: This way, I can move freely.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 反正这里面电应该还够
Tasha: 这个放烤箱里
Tasha: Put this in the oven.
Lucia: 这个也是放这里面吗
Jake: Is this oven a bit crooked?
Katrina:  放这里面吗
Jake: Should this go in here?
Tasha: 你那其实把它放上面也可以
Tasha: Actually, you can put it on top.
Alice:啊，随便放吧。
Jake: 好的
Tasha: Alright.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Lucia: 需要把要洗的东西单独挑出来一下吗
Lucia: Should we separate out the things that need washing?
Jake: 好啊啊你们
Jake: Sure, you guys.
Tasha: 好的对那这个
Tasha: Okay, right, this one.
Jake: 先不给路亚选哦这个底下哈哈哈
Jake: Let's not let Luya choose first, haha.
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 路亚一般不会第一个选是吧
Jake: Luya usually doesn't choose first, right?
Jake: 哦对我一般都follow
Jake: Oh yeah, I usually follow.
Lucia: 就是大家选过的选项
Lucia: Just whatever everyone else has chosen.
Lucia: 就是点菜的时候好那个眼镜把
Lucia: Like when ordering food, alright, those glasses.
Jake: 那边先切吧
Jake: Let's cut over there first.
Jake: 先点吧要不
Jake: How about we order first?
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Tasha: 护护色眼镜
Tasha: Protect your eyes with these glasses.
Lucia: 这个是不是也要拆一下
Lucia: Should we also unwrap this?
Lucia: 就是撒糖霜的那个是吧
Lucia: This is the one with powdered sugar, right?
Shure:  老板你你吃鸡堡
Shure: Boss, do you want a chicken burger?
Shure:  吃牛堡哎
Shure: Or a beef burger?
Jake: 我能吃那个披萨吗
Jake: Can I have the pizza instead?
Shure:  可以Lucia: 这有垃圾桶
Shure: Sure, there's a trash can here.
Shure:  有人吃鸡堡吗
Shure: Anyone wants a chicken burger?
Tasha: 好我不想吃饱
Tasha: No, I don't want to be full.
Shure: 不是奥尔良
Jake: 好那你可以吃
Jake: 那你想吃什么
Jake: So what do you want to eat?
Jake: 你不想吃肯德基是吧
Jake: You don't want KFC, right?
Tasha: 不是不是我不想吃汉堡
Tasha: No, no, I don't want a burger.
Jake: 哦哦哦鸡肉卷
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, chicken wrap!
Lucia: 要帮你吗
Lucia: Do you need help?
Shure:  一个奥尔良
Shure: One 2-ounce.
Shure:  然后一个
Shure: And then one more.
Jake: 好好你帮我推进去
Shure: Alright, you push it in for me.
Jake: 我把这个弄起来
Jake: I'll lift this up.
Tasha: 好
Shure: Alright, OK.
Lucia: 这个袋子要拆掉吗
Lucia: Should I remove this bag?
Tasha: 都要拆的
Tasha: They all need to be removed.
Jake: 走走一波
Tasha: Let’s go.
Tasha: 呃我先把线扯好的
Tasha: Uh, let me pull the cord first.
Jake: 扯掉把线洗
Tasha: Pull it out and wash the cord.
Lucia: 我就把它系一下好了
Lucia: What's going on? I'll just tie it up.
Lucia: 要不然老拖地
Lucia: Otherwise, it keeps dragging.
Tasha: 这其实还可以烤烤鸡来着
Tasha: Actually, you can roast the chicken too.
Jake: 妙妙
Jake: Nice!
Lucia: 裱花嘴一会再拆吧
Lucia: Let's take apart the piping tip later.
Lucia: 别散的不知道到哪去
Lucia: Don't let it scatter everywhere.
Tasha: 这这些都是材
Tasha: These are all ingredients.
Tasha: 食材就行啊
Tasha: Just put the ingredients here.
Tasha: 把粉的放一起
Tasha: Put the powders together.
Tasha: 食材放一起
Tasha: Keep the ingredients together.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Alright, got it.
Lucia: 这些也都要拆掉了是吧对
Lucia: We're taking all these apart too, right?
Lucia: 这都是粉
Lucia: These are all powders.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这些颗都给他
Lucia: Give him all these pieces.
Lucia: 塞一块上
Lucia: Stuff them in together.
Jake: 点完了
Jake: Finished ordering.
Jake: 点了几个
Jake: How many did you order?
Jake: 点了个双人餐
Shure: Ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Really?
Shure:  对那是我
Shure: Yeah, that was me.
Shure:  我点了一个双人餐
Shure: I ordered a meal for two.
Jake: 你一个人点了个双人餐
Jake: You ordered a meal for two by yourself?
Shure:  不是我我和那个
Jake: No, it's for me and...
Shure:  雨轩对
Shure: Yuxuan, yeah.
Jake: 好吃什么呢
Jake: 电池啊
Jake: And the batteries? Ah, batteries.
Alice: 巧克力搁这会不会化呀
Tasha: Will the chocolate explode if left here?
Shure:  要不放冰箱要不放冰箱
Shure: Maybe put it in the fridge.
Tasha: 哦我找着了
Shure: Oh, I found it.
Shure:  辛苦你帮我通知一下
Shure: Could you please notify them for me?
Jake: 找着电池了是吧
Jake: You found the batteries, right?
Tasha: 因为这个电池是我带来的哦
Jake: Because I brought these batteries.
Tasha: 这个里面本来就有放东西
Tasha: There were originally things in here.
Lucia: 应该可以放吸奶油什么的
Lucia: It should be able to hold whipped cream or something.
Tasha: 还有套餐吗哈哈
Tasha: Are there more set meals? Haha.
Jake: 搜一搜
Jake: Clean up.
Jake: 没有哎有是是这个吗
Jake: No, wait, is it this one?
Tasha: 那这不就一个吗
Tasha: Isn't this just one?
Jake: 那就没有了
Tasha: Then there's no more.
Jake:还是这个吧
Tasha: Okay, let's go with this one then.
Jake: 不用套餐好的单点一些喝的是吗
Jake: No need for a set, just order some drinks separately, right?
Jake: 没了还有吗
Tasha: 没了
Alice:我都都搁进去了来
Jake: 来点
Alice: 哇都点好了吗
Alice: Wow, did you order everything?
Jake: 点了三个
Jake: Ordered three things.
Alice:我也不知道点什么别人先点吧
Jake:好那我随便给你点了
Alice: 啊行
Tasha: 粉类可以放
Tasha: 粉类可以放在这里没关系
Tasha: Powder stuff can be placed here, it won't get much sun.
Lucia: 这个地方不是很容易晒到
Alice: 巧克力我都搁那个那里边
Tasha: 巧克力
Alice:给我吧
Tasha: 巧克力可以
Tasha: Chocolate can go in the fridge.
Alice:放冰箱
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: Here's one for you.
Lucia: 这个是放在外面还是要放到冰箱去
Lucia: Should this be kept outside or put in the fridge?
Jake: 你要套餐吗还是单点
Jake: Do you want a set or just order separately?
Alice:随便吧无所谓
Jake: 你要喝的吗
Jake: Do you want a drink?
Alice: 我不要喝的
Jake: Coffee liqueur.
Jake: 你不要喝的
Tasha: 咖啡酒放冰箱好的
Tasha: Coffee liqueur should go in the fridge.
Tasha: 要不这也放冰箱吧
Tasha: Let's put this in the fridge too.
Tasha: 没地方放
Tasha: No space left.
Tasha: 行反正冰箱里东西少空间多
Tasha: Well, there's not much stuff in the fridge, plenty of room.
Tasha: 这个硅油纸啊谁把它放进去的
Tasha: 这个稍微往边上挪一点好
Tasha: Just move this over a bit, it'll be fine.
Jake: 来吧到你了
Jake: Come on, it's your turn.
Lucia: 让我看看大家都点了什么
Lucia: Let me see what everyone ordered.
Shure:  怎么选一堆然后全擦了呢
Shure: How come you picked a bunch and then erased them all?
Lucia: 一般来说
Lucia: Generally speaking,
Lucia: 榴榴莲味的东西都有一点奇奇怪怪的
Lucia: Durian-flavored stuff is always a bit weird.
Lucia: 嗯就是一般我想吃就买这个
Lucia: Well, generally, if I want to eat it, I'll buy this.
Shure:  我呢还有一大瓶伏特加
Shure: And I still have a big bottle of vodka.
Tasha: 真嘟放不下了
Tasha: The temperature can't go down anymore.
Lucia: 哎让我参考一下
Lucia: Hey, let me take a look.
Alice:放上面吧
Alice: 还能看见
Alice: There's another tray.
Tasha: 哎这其实还有个托盘
Tasha: Hey, actually, there's another tray here.
Shure:  你对啥都基本上喝不出它本来
Shure: You basically can't taste its original flavor.
Alice: 但是桌子上没啥位置
Shure: But there's no taste on the table.
Tasha: 那那要不把这这个给挪开
Tasha: Well, how about we move this one away?
Tasha: 把那个水壶也给挪开
Tasha: Move that kettle away too.
Alice:不用那么挤了
Shure:  这是什么呀
Shure: What is this?
Shure:  小甜水
Alice:整齐多了
Jake: 这就是J人
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 我们有几个J人
Shure:  天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Lucia: 万不得已复联计划那种
Lucia: The kind of emergency Avengers plan.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha, XXX.
Alice:放这
Jake: 是j还是p人
Jake: Is it J or P? I'm P.
Jake: p人
Jake: P人j人
Alice: 你觉得呢
Jake: 很J啊
Alice: 我是p
Alice: I am P, VIP.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 唯一的唯一的j人
Jake: The only, the only J person.
Jake: 站着吧完了
Jake: Stand up, it's over.
Jake: 哈哈哈这个地方
Jake: Hahaha, this place.
Jake: 这个地方就是你的
Jake: This place is yours.
Jake: 给你一个
Jake: Give you one.
Jake: 划一个区哈哈
Jake: Draw a zone, haha.
Jake: 哈哈这一区
Lucia: 把J人围起来观察
Jake: Haha, this area is for observing the military.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure:  这一区炸了
Shure: Blowing up the P area, hahaha, what the heck
Jake: 看到这个是不是很不爽
Jake: Seeing this, don't you feel annoyed?
Jake: 这些东西都要把它干掉
Jake: We need to get rid of all these things
Alice: 这个给他搁哪好
Alice: Where should we put this?
Tasha: 这个是备用的刀片
Tasha: This is a spare blade
Tasha: 然后不用搁哪
Tasha: Then, where should we put it?
Tasha: 这个也是
Tasha: Let's just put it here
Alice:搁这吧
Tasha: 我感觉这个没这个好使
Tasha: I feel like this one doesn't work as well as the other one
Alice: 那就给他搁这吧
Alice: Then let's just put it here
Tasha: 嗯行
Jake: Alright
Jake: 这个能晒吗
Jake: Can we dry this?
Jake: 这些东西
Jake: These things
Alice:粉没事
Jake: It's okay, no worries about the powder
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Shure: 不都在阴暗避光
Shure:  保存
Jake:我看一下
Jake: 还有点
Jake: A little bit
Tasha: 玉米油
Tasha: The corn oil also has a bit, which is good
Jake: 行
Jake: Alright
Alice: 哎你放那挡着
Jake: Hey, you put it there and it's blocking the way
Alice: 你拿那些就搁这
Alice: Just put those things here, they won't get in the way
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure:  我们在我们在观摩J人哈哈哈
Shure: We're observing the street garden, hahaha
Lucia: 哎肯德基现在居然还有牛肉汉堡了
Lucia: Hey, KFC actually has beef burgers now
Shure:  他俩应该配料都差不多
Shure: They probably have similar ingredients
Tasha: 到时候就在这裱花吧
Tasha: We'll do the decoration here later
Shure:  对你这这些东西我都拿伏特加对过
Shure: Right, I've used vodka on all these things
Shure:  都基本是一块
Shure: They basically taste the same
Jake: 我先把这个填起来
Jake: I'll fill this up first
Shure:  哎呀哎哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh my, oh my, oh my
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake: 真是多才多艺
Jake: You're really multi-talented.
Lucia: 这是这是怎么发出的声音
Jake: How is this sound being made?
Jake: 12个12个现在
Jake: Twelve, twelve now.
Shure:  差不多就行
Shure: That's about right.
Jake: 环保环保
Jake: Eco-friendly, eco-friendly.
Shure:  啊环保
Jake: Eco, eco-friendly.
Shure:  不能是吧
Shure: It can't be, right?
Shure:  啊那那不行
Shure: Ah, that won't do.
Shure:  纸杯也就不行了
Shure: Paper cups won't work either.
Lucia: 我好了
Shure: I'm good, alright.
Jake:好的
Lucia: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: That's about right.
Shure:  杯子就再说
Shure: As for the cups, we'll discuss it later.
Shure:  先不用买了
Shure: No need to buy them now.
Jake: 我们点了点吧
Jake: Let's order a bit.
Shure:  觉得差不多
Shure: I think that's about right.
Jake: 我们总共三个
Jake: We have a total of three.
Jake: 可乐也行吧
Jake: Coke is fine too, right?
Shure:  好像是我除了可乐
Shure: Seems like besides Coke...
Shure:  我一会要coffee
Shure: I need coffee later.
Shure:  coffee没有coffee会死的
Shure: Without coffee, I'd die.
Jake: 我们要哎
Jake: We need to...
Jake: 肯德基是不是不用餐具点俩吧
Jake: KFC, right? No utensils needed, let's order two.
Lucia: 呃咱们早上有剩下的餐具
Lucia: Uh, we have leftover utensils from the morning.
Lucia: 哦那就点3个因
Lucia: Oh, then let's order three.
Jake: 为剩下的三个是吧
Jake: For the leftovers, right?
Tasha: 什么东西
Jake: Uh, what?
Lucia: 哎不记得剩下几个啊
Lucia: Oh, I don't remember how many are left.
Alice: 餐具
Alice: Utensils, oh wait a minute.
Alice: 动作太大
Alice: Too much movement.
Jake: 好滴点了
Jake: Okay, ordered.
Jake: ok大家等饭吃吧
Jake: Everyone, wait for the food.
Lucia: 我们我们要调几种酒啊
Lucia: How many types of alcohol are we mixing?
Shure:  能调啥基酒的话
Shure: What base alcohol can we mix?
Lucia: 威士忌和龙舌兰也可以考虑一下
Lucia: We can consider whiskey and tequila.
Shure:  没事我明天
Shure: No problem, I vote for sunrise upstairs haha.
Lucia: 我龙舌兰日出一票哈哈
Katrina: 你有这个那就买一瓶
Shure:  我明天回宿舍看看有什么拿点
Shure: Tomorrow I'll check out the dorm and see if there's anything I can take.
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Lucia: 如果买了朗姆的话不买龙舌兰也行
Lucia: 我觉得风味还是有一点相似之处的
Lucia: I think the flavors are somewhat similar.
Jake: 大概去个两次吧应该
Jake: We'll probably go twice, I guess.
Jake: 多的话就只能靠剧组带了
Jake: If it's more, we'll have to rely on the crew.
Tasha: 剧组今天怎么不来
Tasha: Why didn't the crew come today?
Jake: 剧组上课去了啊哈哈
Jake: The crew went to class, haha.
Jake: 剧组很忙
Jake: The crew is really busy.
Jake: 兼组剧组兼职剧组
Jake: The crew does part-time jobs too.
Shure:  精神支柱好吗
Shure: Spiritual support, right?
Lucia: 也可以用气泡酒
Lucia: You can also use sparkling wine.
Tasha: 就是and这一套
Tasha: Like this whole set.
Lucia: mimosa好会也是果汁
Lucia: Mimosa is also good, it's just juice.
Lucia: 果汁味浓一些然后酒精度低过水
Lucia: The juice flavor is stronger and the alcohol content is low.
Jake: 嗯对还有这些
Jake: Yeah, there's also these.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then.
Lucia: 因为我不太确定大家喜欢喝什么样的
Lucia: Because I'm not sure what everyone likes to drink.
Lucia: 我感觉果偏果味的大家应该都能接受
Lucia: I feel like everyone can accept fruity flavors.
Lucia: 我们我们好像还有果粒橙是吧
Lucia: We, we still have pulpy orange juice, right?
Lucia: 那好像不买橙汁也行
Lucia: Then maybe we don't need to buy orange juice.
Katrina: 那要买椰汁吗
Lucia: 椰汁要不先可以加入一下清单
Lucia: Should we add coconut milk to the list first?
Lucia: 然后一会大家考虑一下
Lucia: And then everyone can think about it.
Shure:  哎呦不好意思
Shure: Oh, I'm sorry.
Lucia: 呃我看一下椰林飘香怎么调来着
Lucia: Uh, let me check how to make Pina Colada.
Shure:  行d万能的
Shure: Alright, it's all-purpose.
Shure:  啊西柚味那个是容器
Shure: Ah, the grapefruit flavor, that's for the container.
Katrina: 西柚味
Shure:  这些喝不了
Shure: We can't drink these.
Shure:  就当随时的饮料用
Shure: Just use them as casual drinks.
Alice: 需要洗吗
Alice: Do we need to wash this?
Tasha: 他说他洗啊洗
Tasha: He said wash it, yeah.
Jake: 哈哈对对对
Jake: Haha, yeah, exactly.
Tasha: 休息一下
Tasha: Take a break.
Tasha: 你已经整理过很多东西了
Tasha: You've already sorted out a lot of stuff.
Alice: 没关系的
Jake: It's okay, really.
Jake: 休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Jake: 拼拼图
Jake: Take a break from working so hard.
Jake: 打散了再拼一次
Jake: Rest and then we'll go again.
Jake: 拼拼图
Jake: Ah, taking a break.
Jake: 打散了再拼一次
Jake: Rest and then we'll go again.
Alice:算算算了
Jake: Why, count it.
Alice: 了不想看见他了
Alice: I don't want to see him anymore.
Jake: 休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Jake: 或者你们上楼或者转一转
Jake: Or you guys can go upstairs or take a walk.
Shure:  装完所有零件
Shure: Finish assembling all the parts.
Shure: 发现多出来一颗螺丝 之前装电脑就是
Shure: Or help with the previous computer assembly.
Jake: 一起帮他填片白板吧
Shure: Just help him with filling in the whiteboard.
Shure:  我把那个笔记本拆了清灰然后全拆完
Jake: I took apart the laptop, cleaned the dust, and then reassembled it.
Shure:  最后都装回去
Shure: Finally put everything back.
Jake: 帮我把这些东西都给扔出去吧
Shure: Help me throw all this stuff out.
Jake: 要不就是没用的东西都给扔出去
Jake: Or just throw out the useless stuff.
Jake: 对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, exactly that.
Jake: 然后他们采购的东西补一补
Jake: And then restock the things they purchased.
Alice:这都是要扔的吧
Lucia: 就是朗姆酒加椰汁兑
Lucia: Just mix rum with coconut milk.
Lucia: 然后我个人觉得可能就菠萝汁
Lucia: And personally, I think maybe just use pineapple juice.
Lucia: 换成别的果汁也行
Lucia: You can replace it with other fruit juices too.
Lucia: 因为咱也不需要调的那么正经嘛对吧
Lucia: Because we don't need to make it so formal, right?
Lucia: 所以可以考虑一下
Lucia: So we can consider that.
Lucia: 对我
Lucia: Yeah, I...
Lucia: 其实我觉得只要有可乐
Lucia: Actually, I think as long as we have cola
Lucia: 跟任何东西都可以兑一起是的
Lucia: We can mix it with anything.
Alice: 你做甜品的时候可以帮你
Tasha: Hey, I can help you when you make desserts.
Tasha: 好啊
Tasha: Sure, that's super.
Alice:我是一个超级好的打下手的帮手
Jake: 然后20分钟之内
Jake: And within 20 minutes
Jake: 呃就就把这些事情都给截掉
Jake: Uh, just get all these things done.
Jake: 然后是一个完整的片段
Jake: Then it will be a complete segment.
Jake: 好吧
Shure: Alright, let's get this segment done.
Shure:  好那我们就是5个p人观察一个勾人的计划
Shure: It's about five batches of people observing a captivating plan.
Jake: 对就是我们现在就收尾
Shure: Yeah, we're wrapping up now.
Jake: 就不要开心的事情了就把这个给收掉
Jake: Let's not focus on happy things, just wrap this up.
Jake: 稳
Lucia: 那我们就大家围在一起观察一下吧
Jake: Alright, everyone gather around and observe.
Tasha: 帮我写一下
Tasha: Help me write it down.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Jake: Are you guys making eggs or not?
Jake: 你们要不坐
Shure:  鸡蛋每天早上咱们可以煮着吃
Shure: We can boil eggs every morning, sterile eggs.
Alice:无菌蛋
Tasha: 鸡蛋每天早上煮
Tasha: Boil eggs every morning.
Tasha: 嗯白糖是不是也没有
Lucia: Hmm, we don't have any white sugar, right?
Alice: 有糖粉但是没白糖
Alice: We have powdered sugar, but no white sugar.
Alice: 可是我觉得白糖其实呃好一些
Alice: But I think white sugar is actually better.
Tasha: 嗯买吧白糖还有盐也需要一小包
Tasha: Hmm, let's buy some white sugar and a small bag of salt too.
Alice:买吧
Tasha: 你可以写在一起
Tasha: You can write it together.
Tasha: 要不要一次性餐具
Tasha: Do we need disposable tableware?
Tasha: 盐一次性餐具
Tasha: Salt, disposable tableware is not eco-friendly.
Shure: 不环保
Katrina: 不环保那他们拿啥吃呢
Shure:  手抓哈哈哈
Shure: Use your hands, haha.
Katrina: 手抓
Katrina: 白糖盐
Tasha: 嗯等一下我从第一个开始看牛奶
Tasha: Hmm, wait a minute, let me check the first one, milk.
Shure:  还有个雪克锅的
Tasha: And we need a shaker.
Shure:  嗯这个这可以
Shure: Hmm, this can be used for whipping cream.
Shure:  晚上整一个寿喜锅吃
Shure: Let's have sukiyaki for dinner.
Alice:鸡蛋的
Jake: Sukiyaki, hmm, with eggs.
Alice: 用无菌蛋吧
Alice: Use sterile eggs.
Tasha: 对用无菌蛋也更好一些了
Tasha: Yeah, using sterile eggs is better.
Shure:  那还可以生吃
Shure: Then we can eat them raw.
Shure:  每天早上
Shure: Every morning.
Tasha: 呃鸡蛋汤
Tasha: Uh, egg soup.
Tasha: 嗯也可以买点装饰薄荷什么
Tasha: Hmm, we can also buy some decorative mint or something.
Tasha: 调酒是不是也可以用
Tasha: Can we use it for cocktails too?
Tasha: 薄荷百里香什么都可以
Tasha: Mint, thyme, any of those would work.
Tasha: 保鲜膜保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film, cling film.
Tasha: 这有吗
Tasha: Do we have it? No, we don't.
Jake:没有
Jake: 呃我没看到应该没有吧
Jake: Uh, I didn't see it, probably not.
Jake: 路亚看过没有对吧
Jake: Did you check with Lure? No, right?
Lucia: 没有应该是没有
Lucia: No, probably not.
Lucia: 应该没有
Lucia: Shouldn't be.
Lucia: 好的他们这餐具只有
Lucia: Well, they only have tableware.
Lucia: 比如说那个锅碗瓢盆这些
Lucia: Like, pots, pans, dishes, that sort of thing.
Tasha: 嗯淡奶油
Lucia: Hmm, heavy cream.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 鸡蛋淀粉嗯盐盐液小糖牛奶淡奶油
Tasha: Eggs, cornstarch, hmm, salt, salt solution, a bit of sugar, milk, heavy cream.
Tasha: 如果有一小包的奶粉也可以带一包
Tasha: If there's a small packet of milk powder, we can bring that too.
Tasha:盐 一一包奶粉
Tasha: Salt, one packet of milk powder.
Tasha: 咖啡粉咖啡粉手冲吧
Tasha: Coffee powder, coffee powder, let's do a pour-over.
Shure:  跟那个不一样吧
Shure: Isn't that different?
Shure:  你要的是什么咖啡
Shure: What kind of coffee do you need?
Tasha: 我就要一包咖啡粉
Katrina: 做提拉米苏吧
Tasha: 啊对
Lucia: 喝的咖啡粉可以吗
Tasha: 啊你们不磨吗
Tasha: Ah, you don't grind it yourself?
Tasha: 啊我也想买点咖啡条喝万一嘛
Tasha: Ah, I also want to buy some coffee or tea, just in case.
Jake: 哎我我还带了一个咖鸭
Jake: Hey, I brought some coffee duck.
Jake: 就是新加坡的一个很很奇怪的调料
Jake: It's a weird seasoning from Singapore.
Tasha: 也可以再写蛋挞皮
Alice: 这个纸箱还要吗
Alice: Do we still need this cardboard box?
Lucia: 这纸箱要不要留一下
Lucia: Should we keep this cardboard box?
Jake: 假如我们留着留着
Jake: If we keep it...
Jake: 对对假如我们要做一些什么纸箱
Jake: Yeah, if we need to do something with it.
Lucia: 狗之类的可以摆在门口
Lucia: Like, maybe put a dog at the entrance.
Lucia: 然后就当迎宾
Lucia: And have it as a greeter.
Alice: 那能把纸箱都留着
Alice: Then let's keep all the cardboard boxes.
Jake: 对纸箱留着吧
Jake: Yeah, let's keep the cardboard boxes.
Jake: 放在外面那种
Jake: Put them outside.
Lucia: 那种特别软特别薄的就不需要了
Jake: The really soft and thin ones we don't need.
Lucia: 或者说就是破破那家咖啡馆的
Lucia: Or the ones that are too damaged, like the ones from the coffee shop.
Tasha: 不用咖啡房
Tasha: No need for the coffee room.
Tasha: 没事我来吧
Tasha: It's okay, I'll do it.
Alice: 就搁这吧
Alice: Just leave it here.
Lucia: 他我明天可以查查看
Shure: I can check it out tomorrow.
Lucia: 那个布丁应该怎么做
Lucia: How should we prepare the supplies?
Shure:  我今天回家啊我回宿舍补给
Shure: I'll go home today, back to the dorm to resupply.
Tasha: 然后再买草莓
Tasha: Then buy some strawberries.
Shure:  想想啊有音箱话筒然后咖啡
Shure: Let's see, there's the speaker, microphone, then coffee, wine, and strawberries.
Lucia: 草莓能放几天啊
Lucia: How long can strawberries last?
Tasha: 草莓能放
Tasha: Strawberries can last.
Tasha: 放冰箱的话两三天吧
Tasha: If you put them in the fridge, maybe two or three days.
Shure:  3天吧
Shure: Three days, I guess.
Jake: 3天我们不会吃吗
Jake: We won't eat them in three days?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 那就大概过上三四天左右再去
Lucia: Then maybe we should buy them again in three or four days.
Lucia: 买一次对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 那就没有了
Tasha: Then we're out.
Lucia: 外援
Lucia: External support.
Shure:  不咖啡豆没了
Shure: No, I'm out of coffee beans.
Alice:还没手好使呢
Shure:  我需要买
Shure: I need to buy some.
Shure:  趁机补给我对
Shure: I'll resupply, right.
Shure:  咖啡的一些东西对
Shure: Some coffee stuff, right.
Lucia: 这个手套要不
Lucia: What about these gloves?
Lucia: 放这好了
Lucia: Let's put them here.
Jake: 对我们这边只有一个j
Jake: Yeah, we only have one J here.
Jake: 然后没有s
Jake: And no S.
Lucia: 竟然没有s
Lucia: There's no S?
Lucia: 没有s
Lucia: No S.
Jake: 是我们总共30多个报名的人里边
Jake: Out of the more than 30 people who signed up,
Jake: 就三个要
Jake: only three want
Jake: 要就两个s
Jake: 嗯s是啥
Jake: Hmm, what is S?
Alice: s觉得这种事没有意义
Alice: S thinks this is pointless.
Lucia: 有可能s比较
Lucia: Maybe S is more
Jake: s是是啥好像是
Jake: S is like, what, emotional
Jake: 什么感性和直觉和感觉
Jake: and intuitive and feeling.
Lucia: 直觉和感觉
Lucia: Intuition and feeling
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah, the actual feeling.
Alice:实感
Jake: 就这个实在是没法打官司
Jake: You really can't go to court over this.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: 那所以是p人更多还是j人更多
Lucia: So, are there more fake people or real people?
Lucia: 按照按照就是最终的结果来说的话
Lucia: According to the final result...
Lucia: 应该报名的时候也是p人多
Lucia: During the registration, there were more fake people.
Jake:对对对压倒性子
Lucia: Yes, yes, it was overwhelming.
Jake: 对p人多
Jake: Yeah, more fake people.
Tasha: 为什么p人多
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, why were there more fake people?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 这个可以扔了吗
Lucia: Can I throw this away?
Lucia: 这里面还有一个
Lucia: There's one more inside.
Lucia: 这个也
Lucia: This one too.
Lucia: 应该也是裱花嘴的时候要扔了啊
Lucia: Should we throw away the piping tip too?
Tasha: 对这是转换器
Tasha: Yes, that's the converter.
Lucia: 那这个放在跟那些放一起吧
Lucia: Let's put this with those things.
Lucia: 然后这个可以扔了对吧
Lucia: And we can throw this away, right?
Lucia: 对那就扔掉了
Lucia: Yes, let's throw it away.
Jake: 就是第一波那个
Jake: It's from the first batch.
Jake: 呃复活节的那一次
Jake: Uh, the one during Easter.
Jake: 呃那报名的里边只有三个
Jake: There were only three people who signed up.
Jake: 只有三种
Jake: Only three kinds.
Jake: 只有只有三种
Jake: 这个NBTI只有三种
Jake: This NBTI only has three kinds.
Jake: 对总共十几个人总共
Jake: Yeah, there were a dozen people in total.
Alice:把这个喝了吧
Shure: Let's just drink it.
Lucia: 幸好最后我没有复活
Lucia: Thankfully, I didn't resurrect.
Lucia:节举办因为突然
Lucia: The ending because suddenly...
Lucia: 就是就是突然之间
Lucia: It just happened suddenly.
Lucia: 我就是那一周事情还蛮多的
Lucia: I had quite a lot going on that week.
Lucia: 然后我一直忙到就是来这之前的一周
Lucia: And I was busy up until the week before coming here.
Shure:  哎这有一篇那个
Shure: Hey, there's this article that's kind of a coincidence.
Lucia: 很荣幸认识大家
Lucia: It's an honor to meet everyone.
Alice: 对要做那啥的啊
Alice: Yeah, we need to do that thing.
Alice:这个不能动他
Tasha: Haha, don't touch that.
Tasha: 这还可以煮火锅哎
Tasha: We can even cook hotpot with this.
Alice: 把这个也打了吧
Alice: Let's add this too.
Jake: 搞一天火锅
Jake: Have a hotpot day.
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: Sure, sounds good.
Lucia: 哎对火锅也比较方便
Lucia: Right, hotpot is quite convenient.
Lucia: 买一些简单的食材
Lucia: Just buy some simple ingredients.
Lucia: 火锅直接煮就好了
Lucia: Hotpot is just easy to cook.
Lucia: 丸子羊肉片对
Lucia: Meatballs, lamb slices, yeah.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Yeah, we can do that.
Lucia: 我们自己做饭的环节
Lucia: For our cooking segment,
Lucia: 不如就做火锅
Lucia: Why don't we just do hotpot?
Alice: 这是我们买的
Alice: This is what we bought.
Alice: : 放进去可以
Jake: Put it in, sure.
Shure:  他这冰箱全是空的
Shure: His fridge is completely empty.